video footage that surfaced on social
media the week of November 14th appears
to show Ukrainian troops shooting
surrendering Russian soldiers in the
village of makivka in the luhansk region
the footage has raised accusations of
war crimes by both Ukrainian and Russian
soldiers
in this video clip the person filming
wears a yellow armband an identifier
used by Ukrainian troops he turns the
camera toward what appeared to be
Russian soldiers wearing red bands as
they exit a brick shed and lie down one
by one
foreign
what looks to be another Russian soldier
emerges from the shed and opens fire
Drone footage captured above the same
brick shed shows nearly a dozen Soldiers
with the same characteristic markings
and gear as the soldiers believed to
have been Russian
Russian officials have said the video
shows ukrainians intentionally executing
unarmed prisoners of War
Ukrainian officials say the Russian
soldiers were faking their surrender to
attack the Ukrainian soldiers both
scenarios would be considered war crimes
Russian officials said they will bring
the ukrainians responsible to Justice
the Ukrainian government has said it
will investigate the videos the United
Nations human rights office has also
called for an investigation